[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici au parlement européen à bruxelles
dans cette émission plonger dans les
méandres de la politique agricole
commune 1er budget de l'union européenne
celle-ci est actuellement en cours de
renégociation pour la période 2020
2027 et c'est peu dire que le lobbying
est intense nous avons voulu sonder les
attentes des agriculteurs sur la
question
reportages et débats à suivre mais
d'abord l'actualité mario centeno
ministre des finances du gouvernement de
gauche portugais a fait ses premiers pas
de président de l'eurogroupe
tout un symbole quand on sait que cet
économiste à redresser son pays en
allant à l'encontre des préconisations
de la commission et du même regroupe à
quelques mois d'un renouvellement du
directoire de la banque centrale
européenne faut-il y voir un changement
de doctrine
on fait le point avec amelia marghadi et
qui me disent anne
[Musique]
dans le petit monde de l'économie
européenne la guerre entre les faucons
adepte de la rigueur et les colombes
pour l'assouplissement monétaire fait
rage depuis le 13 janvier
le ministre des finances du portugal
mario centeno est à la tête de
l'eurogroupe
l'élection de cet homme de gauche
surnommé le ronaldo de la finance à la
présidence de l'instance de décision des
pays membres de la zone euro fait
espérer un changement de doctrine
notamment dans les pays du sud de
l'europe qui ne goûte guère l'orthodoxie
budgétaire de l'allemagne de ses alliés
mais si la gauche a obtenu le poste de
président de l'eurogroupe s'est surtout
la succession du président de la bce
mario draghi qui fait débat
d'ici à la fin 2010 9 les deux tiers de
la direction de la banque centrale
européenne seront renouvelés et berlin
compte bien faire main basse sur
l'institution en gala merkel et son
ancien ministre des finances wolfgang
schauble eux entendent placer un faucon
sur le trône et stopper la politique
monétaire du président italien de la
banque centrale considérée comme trop
généreuse leurs favoris james weidmann
patron de la bundesbank et adversaires
des déficits excessifs
face à la stratégie allemande les pays
du sud de l'europe surnommé
maladroitement club med parents gay la
merkel débute également les grandes
manoeuvres
l'espagne et la france poussent leurs
candidats dont le gouverneur de la
banque de france françois villeroy de
galop derrière ces valse de nominations
se joue aussi une bataille de doctrine
alors quelle politique économique pour
l'europe de demain pour en débattre j'ai
le plaisir de recevoir philippe lambert
bonjour à ginette coprésident du groupe
des verts au sein de ce parlement
alors on voit mario centeno tout le
monde s'est dépêché de dire que c'était
peut-être un changement de doctrine au
niveau de l'eurogroupe c'est le ronaldo
de les copines
est-ce qu'il faut y voir ici un symbole
ou est ce que finalement on est juste
dans ce qu'on voit d'habitude c'est à
dire un système de placement entre les
groupes qui vont vouloir quelqu'un à
gauche là quelqu'un à droite à la tête
d'une autre institution
les gens n'ont peut-être pas remarqué
mais celui à qui monsieur saint thélo
succèdent et irun des seuls blum lui
aussi il est socialiste est paraît-il
évidemment rien ne peut rien ne permet
de le savoir puisque il a mené une
politique d'une orthodoxie absolument à
toute épreuve dont cette année au
libéral pur jus mario centeno n'est pas
un gauchiste il faut pas exagérer mais
clairement prend ses distances je pense
que ce qui est en train de se passer au
delà des nominations c'est une évolution
lente dans l'establishment économique
européen donc qui regroupe les
ministères des finances les banques
centrales et la direction générale
économique et financière la commission
européenne ce que je pense qui est en
train de se jouer
faut bien écouter ce que mario draghi
dit il faut bien écouter certains
discours de responsables européens
c'est qu'il ya une forme d'inquiétude
donc certes la croissance est de retour
mais mais les voyants ne sont pas au
vert mais c'est à dire que cette
croissance ne profite pas à tout le
monde loin loin loin de là et donc il ya
une étude révélant tout démontre que
l'égalité entre les personnes n'a jamais
été aussi forte au sein de l'ignorer
évidemment l'inégalité été aussi forte
la dernière fois c'était avant le
premier conflit mondial et on a vu ce
que ça a donné alors je ne nie pas qu'il
ya un lien de cause à effet mais il ya
des liens en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que l'an dernier où que cela nous
l'a rappelé encore tout récemment 82% du
de la richesse économique a été captées
par 1% de la population et cette
proportion augmente chaque année et donc
je pense qu' une certaine inquiétude de
la part des orthodoxes
je veux qu'il ya quand même quelque
chose qui ne va pas et donc on a entendu
mario draghi a appelé à une plus juste
répartition des fruits de la croissance
il était mis aussi ce qui était interdit
également
alors on est encore très loin du compte
et les faucons et à leur tête wolverine
chase sont toujours à l'affût mais
volkan shop ce n'est plus ministre des
finances allemand et donc pris la tête
du bundestag et donc je pense que le
contexte pourrait se prêter à un
meilleur équilibre dans la politique
économique donc une hirondelle ne fait
pas le printemps mais en tout cas on
sent bien que les plaques tectoniques
sont en train de bouger alors je vous
rassure pas au point de dire que nous
devons retrouver une société et une
économie sociale de marché où les fruits
de la croissance sont très justement
distribués
on voit bien que même chez les
ultra-orthodoxes cette idée quand même
que seul 1% de la population au profit
de la croissance ça c'est quand même un
peu exagéré
ça pouvait être cinq ou six ça serait le
mieux oui on n'est pas encore très loin
d'un homme et non pas qu une égalité
parfaite ils sont pas convertis à la
justice sociale ou insu après il ya
quand même aussi une question de réforme
de la zone euro et ça pour l'état on a
l'impression aussi que cela fait
consensus au sein de l'eurogroupe et
même plus largement c'est à dire que ces
nouvelles nominations dont celle de
mario centeno est aussi une une preuve
que il va pouvoir
on va pouvoir faire quelque chose sur
cette nécessaire démocratisation de la
zone euro dans la lignée de ce que
souhaitent emmanuel macron par exemple
alors j'ai bien sûr le thème que vous
utilisez démocratisation de la zone euro
on peut penser démocratisation sur le
plan institutionnel que la prise de
décision soient plus transparentes que
les décideurs en plus de comptes aux
élus et puis c'est la démocratisation
par les résultats autrement dit que la
politique économique profite au plus
grand nombre et pas juste à une minorité
je pense que les conditions sont en
train d'évoluer et clairement certains
éléments de la proposition d' emmanuel
macron vont dans le bon sens jeudi si
vous avez une union monétaire matinée de
compétition fiscale et sociale
le résultat mécanique de ce choix
politique et le nivellement par le bas
les phénomènes sociaux et fiscaux
donc c'est évident que aller dans le
sens d'une plus grande harmonisation
fiscale et d'une harmonisation sociale
vers le haut
clairement permettrait une distribution
plus juste des fruits de l'activité
économique donc dans ce sens là les
propositions des manuels macron vont
dans le bon sens je crois qu'il faut pas
accorder trop d'importance à la question
d'un ministre des finances européen dans
la zone euro sepa
monde la zone euro non c'est quand même
à un moment quand il ya des prises de
décision on l'a vu dans le cas de la
crise là qu'il est aussi nécessaire
d'avoir un contrôle démocratique bien
sûr une instance génialement qui n'a
aussi ce parlement ici c'est par de
nombreux pays européens le parlement de
la zone schengen c'est le parlement
européen on n'a pas fait un parlement à
dos figure et spécialement par les pays
de l' delà de la zone schengen pour
assurer le contrôle démocratique de ce
qui se passe dans la zone schengen même
chose pour la zone euro car le centre de
gravité a fait l'immense majorité
non je veux dire comme ça les pays de la
zone euro constitue de toute façon la
majorité déterminante du parlement
européen ceci étant si un jour nous
devions avoir des éléments du budget
européen qu'ils sont exclusivement liés
à la zone euro
on pourrait envisager des procédures de
vote au parlement européen où on tienne
on exige qu'il y ait en tout cas une
majorité non seulement dans l'ensemble
du parlement européen
mais dans les représentants des pays de
la zone euro ça n'est pas très compliqué
à mettre en place
faut-il ne faut-il pas un changement de
traité ça ça vous savez on pourrait
créer dans l'absolu une commission
ad-hoc santé allemand mais bien sûr donc
il faut pas inventer un nouveau machin
je veux dire on se plaint déjà souvent
que le parlement européen est à
bruxelles et à strasbourg sur voulait
encore ajouter un troisième parlement
enfin je veux dire un troisième site
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
et dans ce sens là des propositions
d'actions vont dans le bon sens la
question c'est va-t-il aller se battre
voulait-il aller à la faillite parce que
il faut pas s'imaginer que ça va se
passer dans la joie et la bonne humeur
le camp de l'orthodoxie restes
fossilisés intellectuellement et à un
moment ça va devoir être rugueux et va
falloir voir si macro est prêt à une
certaine rugosité entre paris et la leur
la rugosité va peut-être être aussi
fluidifier si toutefois une grosse
coalition passe entre les
sociaux-démocrates de martin schulz et
en galerie simplement
c'est ce qu'ont été les sablons nos
alliés je ne voyais pas dans la mauvaise
a eu l'idée d'une coalition avec les
chrétiens-démocrates et libéraux et les
verts mais il est évident que les
libéraux allemands sont devenus
eurosceptiques farouche et qu'avec eux
il aurait été impossible
ne serait-ce que de mettre en discussion
les idées avancées par emmanuel macron
par l'italie par l'espagne jeudi à reims
et emmanuel macron n'a pas inventé la
poudre
d'autres ont fait ce genre de
proposition avant lui il ferait bien
d'ailleurs de se coaliser avec eux mais
une grande coalition en allemagne avec
les socialistes rendraient plus facile
une discussion constructive entre paris
et berlin
alors c'est l'heure du tchèque pas une
philippe lambert de cette semaine xavier
lambert se penche sur les raisons pour
lesquelles les migrants souhaite
rejoindre la grande bretagne la barre on
pourrait semble-t-il travailler
facilement sans papiers vrai faux
le checkpoint s'est tout de suite la
grande bretagne
l'eldorado des migrants ils veulent tous
aller en angleterre parce que là on peut
bosser sans papiers d'identité c'est
plus facile d'y travailler illégalement
ses croyances sur les migrants sont
alimentés par des discours politiques
comme celui de l'ancien député français
xavier bertrand pourquoi ils veulent
aller en angleterre et acheter du boulot
et surtout et surtout vous pouvez bosser
là bas sans papiers d'identité alors
l'angleterre un eldorado la jungle de
calais a été démantelée il ya un an déjà
mais les associations dénombre encore
plus de 700 migrants au bord de la
manche
pourtant les contrôles aux frontières
ont été renforcés et emmanuel macron a
même obtenu une aide financière du
royaume uni les demandes d'asile sont
aujourd'hui moins nombreuses ils sont
aussi moins souvent accordé malgré cela
des centaines de migrants et c'est
encore chaque jour de traverser la
manche
pourquoi pour la communauté notamment
selon une étude récente
62% des candidats disent connaître
quelqu'un sur place la langue joue aussi
un rôle important
les migrants maîtrise généralement mieux
l'anglais il pense dès lors s'intégrer
aisément et enfin et surtout pour le
travail avec un taux de 4,2 pour cent le
chômage est à son niveau le plus bas
depuis les années 70
de quoi séduire les candidats à l'exil
qui s'imaginent pouvoir y travailler
sans papiers
ym possible pour conduire un véhicule
loué un logement ou obtenir un emploi
grande bretagne il faut désormais un de
ces documents le biométrique residence
permis pour ceux qui ont obtenu un titre
de séjour ou une application registre
hession cordes destinés aux demandeurs
d'asile
ceci le peuvent normalement pas
travailler mais ils peuvent obtenir une
dérogation qui doit être notifiée sur
leur carte
de plus le gouvernement a durci sa loi
immigration des employeurs britanniques
doivent non seulement exigé mais aussi
vérifier les documents
il risque jusqu'à 5 ans de prison s'ils
emploient des illégaux et ce n'est pas
qu'un effet d'annonce 2000 condamnations
ont été prononcées en 2015 donc dire que
l'on peut travailler sans papiers en
angleterre parce qu'il n'y a pas de
contrôle c'est faux philippe lambert ce
quand on voit ça on sait que les
britanniques vont sortir de l'union
européenne est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
à terme que les britanniques gère les
flux de migrants qu'ils soient qui
souhaitent accéder à la grande motte n a
en tout cas fait leurs ambitions ils ont
fait le référendum sur le thème de take
back control reprendre le contrôle en
effet ça sera leur problème et vous
savez les états y compris les états de
les 27 états récent de l'union ont la
furieuse habitude de vouloir
externaliser la gestion de l'affronter
vous savez les britanniques
externalisant france les français les
italiens et érythréenne soudanaise
les membres des bandes armées libyennes
pour garder ces sauvages loin de chez
nous parce que fondamentalement c'est ça
la politique migratoire européenne c'est
que ces gens meurent du moment que c'est
droite dans camera voilà et donc je
pense qu'il faut trouver le juste
équilibre l'europe ne peut pas
accueillir tout le monde
mais beaucoup de pays en europe peuvent
faire beaucoup plus que ce qu'ils font
aujourd'hui sans mettre en péril la
cohésion de nos sociétés écouter de
façon reviendra sur cette question
puisque un paquet migratoires ne va pas
tarder à être présentée par la
commission merci bon avec les élus
lambertz
alors on continue il ya quelques
semaines les négociations débutées pour
la future politique agricole commune 1er
budget de l'union européenne celle-ci se
voit désormais remise en cause par de
nouvelles priorités investissements
lutte contre le terrorisme politique
migratoire on en parlait alors
agriculture verte maîtrise des marchés
gestion crise nous avons voulu sonder
les agriculteurs
sur leurs attentes sur cette nouvelle
pac reportage de quentin calmet et kim
vivan
[Musique]
dans les deux sèvres
cela fait dix ans que vincent touzeau a
repris les 125 hectares de
l'exploitation agricole de son père
c'est un troupeau de vaches laitières
donc il y en a 50 dans le bâtiment donc
ce sont des holstein une race qui a été
sélectionné pour produire du lait
produire du lait une gageur ces
dernières années lorsqu'il s'est
installé cet agriculteur ne s'attendait
pas à traverser de telles zones de
turbulences car personne n'imaginait
alors que les prix du lait pouvait
s'effondrer en quelques saisons on a eu
une ou deux premières années qui sont
bien passées et puis depuis quand même
le prix du lait qui est trop bas et puis
les céréales aussi qu'ils sont
effondrées depuis un ou deux ans là donc
on essaye de passer le cap même si c'est
quand même quelques sacrifices en termes
de modes de rémunération ça peut être du
décalage d'investissements ça peut être
plein de choses et donc il faut quand
même passer le cap et puis essayer de
trouver des solutions au niveau de
l'exploitation et puis aussi compter sur
des évolutions la politique agricole
après tout c'est un reproche de la
profession en libéralisant les marchés
la politique agricole commune a
fragilisé les exploitations
les producteurs de lait sont ainsi
devenus très vulnérable au cours du
marché
la pac actuelle aussi à s'est
complètement désengagée de la gestion
des marchés et pour nous c'est un
problème qui se traduit aujourd'hui par
la crise dans le lait les prix bas au
niveau des céréales un certain nombre de
deux cycles de prix bas que traverse
d'autres productions d'autres filières
donc ça c'est extrêmement important de
le souligner est que un des enjeux aussi
de demain c'est que la policière écoles
se réapproprie aussi cette question de
la gestion des marchés de la gestion de
crise
ce sentiment de fragilité des
exploitations il est partagé à l'autre
bout de la france
ici en normandie arnold puech d'alissac
élève des volailles et des vaches la pac
représente 15% de ses revenus soit
environ trente six mille euros versés
par an une somme devenu indispensable
dans la majorité des exploitations
agricoles françaises sur le marché
unique
l'agriculture est devenue ultra
concurrentiel entre producteurs
européens une obsession pour cet éleveur
membre de la fnsea gagner sa vie en
vendant des produits moins cher qu'avant
c'est compliqué c'est très compliqué
donc vont produire de plus en plus avec
la réforme prévue pour 2020 ils
s'inquiètent d'une possible
renationalisation de la pac avec des
objectifs de production qui serait fixée
par la france et non au niveau européen
on a très peur d'une trop forte
renationalisation la politique qu'elle
est agricole et commune elle doit être
partagée est la plus proche entre
nous et nos collègues ça c'est mes
vieilles poules
selon cet éleveur ce sont bien les
exigences environnementales fixées par
la france qui freine le rendement des
agriculteurs ces normes sont perçus
comme tatillonne bureaucratique voir
punitive par une partie de la profession
faisant grimper les coûts elles
empêcheraient les éleveurs français
d'être aussi compétitifs que leurs
concurrents européens
la croissance de la production doit être
soutenu quand il ya une demande mondiale
en asie extraordinaire et que c'est les
autres pays l'union européenne qui la
font qu'ils répondent à cette demande
mais la france est idiote
depuis plusieurs mois un autre syndicat
agricole planche également sur cette
sixième réforme de la pac
la confédération paysanne prône une
transition vers un autre modèle agricole
abandonnant le productivisme ce jour là
ils sont une dizaine d'agriculteurs
venus plancher au sein d'un groupe de
travail
ici l'objectif est bien de bouleverser
le modèle agricole actuel les besoins de
la société française et européenne c'est
de préserver une ressource naturelle
c'est de rémunérer les producteurs et
surtout et d'abord de produire une
alimentation saine en quantité
suffisante jeunes agriculteurs fnsea
confédération paysanne
chaque camp fourbit actuellement ses
armes l'occasion pour chacun de défendre
sa vision du modèle agricole pour les
générations à venir
[Musique]
alors quelle politique agricole commune
pour demain pour en débattre j'ai
plaisir de recevoir michel dantin
bonjour un gel est député européen
membre du parti populaire européen donc
les lr bienvenue à vous en face de vous
eric andrieu vous vous faites partie du
groupe des socialistes et démocrates
vous êtes tous les deux des spécialistes
de la question agricole
alors peut-être un mot sur ce reportage
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire de ce que
vous avez entendu à ce qu'on peut
concilier toutes ses volontés que ce
soit des jeunes agriculteurs de la fnsea
ou de la confédération paysanne
michel dantin qu'est ce que vous avez
retenu de ce reportage oui il ya une
volonté très simple qui les réunit tous
et qui nous réunit c'est celle de
pouvoir vivre dignement vivre dignement
est ce à dire que jusqu'ici les
agriculteurs en fait ont eu des
difficultés en fait à vivre de leurs de
leur savoir faire
oui je crois que moi je partage une il
est là le seul objectif qui nous anime
c'est comment évidement on arrive à
sécuriser le revenu des agriculteurs
veut et comment nous pouvons permettre
nous sommes dans nos politiques
publiques de faire en sorte que sur un
territoire les métiers de l'agriculture
puisse d'être suffisamment rémunérateur
pour maintenir la vie sur ces
territoires ruraux
parce qu'on voit bien effectivement et
notamment avec la crise du lait que
beaucoup d'agriculteurs aujourd'hui
travaillent à perte sont incapables de
se payer un agriculteurs se suicident
tous les trois jours c'est aujourd'hui
aussi à cela que la pac de demain va
devoir faire face
michel dantin oui évidemment l'impact de
demain est là d'abord pour moi une
vocation économique
beaucoup de gens veulent venir picorer
dans l'assiette ou occuper le noailhac
l'assiette est bonne en politique mais
il faut replacer les choses à leur juste
place
quand vous rapporter au nombre
d'agriculteurs et aux surfaces que cela
représente
l'aide est finalement par individu
insignifiante
donc effectivement enfance je fais
souvent une comparaison quand j'avais 20
ans c'est-à-dire à l'âge du service
militaire il était de bon aloi taper sur
la défense de contester l'armée et c'est
parce que c'était le plus gros budget or
aujourd'hui en france l'armée n'est plus
une armée de conscription n'entend plus
parler du budget militaire
donc quand vous êtes le plus gros budget
vous faites forcément envie mais il faut
replacer les choses à leur juste place
nous sommes la seule politique où les
états ont décidé en 1962 d'abandonner
les politiques nationales pour avoir une
seule politique européenne et donc comme
nous avons un marché unique
nous voulons que cette politique
agricole reste une politique européenne
et je relève ce qui a été dit dans l'un
des par l'inde et l'une des personnes
interviewées
il faut que la france arrête de vouloir
être plus vertueuses que les autres d'en
rajouter sans arrêt je pense pas que nos
scientifiques soient super plus
intelligents que les scientifiques des
autres pays européens
je pense pas non plus que nos électeurs
soit plus fraudeurs que l'ensemble des
autres agriculteurs est ce à dire que
vous rejoignez la fns là quand elle dit
que c'est dangereux de renationaliser la
politique agricole commune de laisser
les états en fait fixer des priorités
je sais pas que la vie de la fsu asselah
villegia c'est notre avis c'est la vie
je pense de la confédération paysanne
nous ne voulons pas d'une
renationalisation de la pac quoi eric
andrieu quel est le risque d'une
renationalisation cécilia politique
commune aujourd'hui l'agriculture n'est
pas une question locale ni nationale ni
européenne l éducation mondiale parce
que d'abord
l'agriculture n'est pas une économie
comme les autres 4 est donc de la santé
humaine
elle traite de rapport à l'environnement
au bien commun c'est à dire donc balle
au sol à l'air au climat et dont elle a
besoin de politiques publiques est
inscrit dans une dynamique
intercontinental et que donc venez sur
des logiques de concurrence dans un
monde ouvert aujourd'hui et pour ce
faire re nationaliser voudrait dire
restreindre six volets à sa portion
congrue et nos politiques publiques
comme ne serait une politique nationale
agricole
donc aujourd'hui il est bien entendu
qu'on ne peut pas imaginer une
renationalisation de la politique
agricole commune mais ce jeu de rôle par
don lawrence et 500 millions d'européens
donc l'enjeu du marché intérieur il est
à cette échelle là et elle sera plus
fort pour discuter avec nos concurrents
donc faut dire ce qui est de l'offre
sera réunie à l'échelle de l'union
européenne qu'est ce qu'il faut attendre
de la pac de demain quels sont vos au
niveau du parlement européen au niveau
de la commission agriculture
ce qui va être portée en termes
d'objectifs 1 si vous soir que le défi
est que nous partageons je le pense
c'est finalement c'est une image mais
c'est le passé du comment dire du
costume donc du tout venant au
sur-mesure quoi donc c'est à dire donc
il faut qu'on arrive à définir ensemble
les objectifs communs et que l'on puisse
dans la dans le respect de la différence
de la spécificité de nos territoires
mettre en oeuvre des mesures adaptées
pour répondre à tous ces niveaux
d'objectifs donc l'enjeu il est double
c'est un mettre en place des
perspectives communes donc
collectivement et sélective que c'est
une école face à une agriculture plus
verte lui serait effectuée à bord il est
question de l'acte de l'économie alors
que jean majeur c'est la sécurisation du
revenu des agriculteurs bien à travers
leurs reportages it et ça vous êtes
d'accord peut-être tous les deux à
attaquer les phénomènes de rente qu'on
entend souvent à propos de la pac
on a toujours tendance à aller
stigmatiser les céréaliers de la beauce
qui ont tendance à récupérer une grosse
partie en fait des subsides de la pac
il ya une histoire les céréaliers ont eu
des aides qu'ils étaient comme les
producteurs de lait fixé au kilo il
produisait plus donc ils avaient plus d
aide
et quand on a converti le système à
l'hectare c'est apparu aux yeux de tout
le monde
nous avons déjà un mécanisme qui a
commencé à lisser il faut continuer on
peut pas faire autrement il faut compte
nuit à l'isard et les poils juste pour
aller vers elle n'est là qu'il soit là
même au niveau d'un pays
elle restera avec des différences d'un
pays à l'autre pourquoi je me battrai
pour maintenir cette différence parce
que le revenu moyen par habitant en
europe et pas le même entre les
différents pays européens
il n'y a pas de raison que dans un pays
la pac permettent un agriculteur de
n'avoir que 70 % du revenu moyen par
habitant alors que dans un autre pays
elle permettrait d'avoir 300 % du revenu
moyen par habitant
donc nous sommes encore obligé de tenir
compte de ces différences là mais la pac
c'est d'abord un élément économique
pourquoi parce que nous avons un système
en europe qui veut que les coûts de
production soit plus cher qu'ailleurs
dans le monde
or les prix sont aujourd'hui de manière
globale mondiale et plus nous allons
vers une société de l'information plus
nous allons vers une société du
numérique plus la rapidité de
transmission des cours des des de l'état
des cultures etc influera sur les prix
et nous alignera sur des prix mondiaux
mais ce qu'on peut s'aligner sur les
prix qui seront pratiqués dans d'autres
continents et connerie est ce que ce
n'est pas aussi un peu une lubie que de
pouvoir un moment sa ligne et je ne sais
pas sur des pays d'asie sur des magies
d'amérique latine et moi je pense que
nous avons un modèle à défendre oui
d'abord le modèle il faut le transformer
en tous les cas qu'on le veuille ou pas
le modèle lui-même va se transformer
donc parce que le climat change parce
que les technologies vont très vite
aujourd'hui et que les pratiques et les
métiers vont se modifier très vite on
peut pas dire aujourd'hui ce que sera la
vie dure dans 15 ans vraiment il faut
anticiper c'est mon sentiment et ne pas
le gérer et que sinon pour si on doit
pouvoir être donc dans les discussions
sur les accords de libre-échange par
exemple par une concurrente
il faut que défendre un modèle donc ça
veut dire oui l'agriculture doit faire
en lien avec la santé humaine
on est sur des enjeux considérables de
protection de la qualité alimentaire
oui l'agriculture intervient sur le bien
commun qu'est l'environnement et donc la
pac devra accompagner cet aspect là donc
sur ce bien commun d'un héros il devra
mettre en place des mesures de
protection adaptées
oui sur les sols laroque conquête des
sols oui sur le climat parce que
l'agriculture interagit sur le climat
parce que justement il faut que je te
reconnaissance et qu'on remette du sens
et que l'agriculture organe au coeur du
débat politique et en cela il faut qu'on
soit très vigilant par rapport au projet
d'accord de libre-échange en courant
barles du canada quand on parle du
mercosur on le voit bien que ça peut
mettre à mal des modèles de lettres
françaises et européennes et je crois
qu'il faut que nous soyons vigilants
tant à se savoir effectivement est ce
qu'on veut une ruralité vivante avec des
éleveurs en cours dans les zones de
montagne très zones défavorisées je
crois qu'il ya un débat en france la
question des zones à je sais pas des
petites questions parce qu'il faut que
l'on pose des questions d'ordre
politique de savoir a finalement qu'à
l'agriculture nous aspirons les uns et
les autres dernière question messieurs
la france ait fait inédit prête à
sacrifier la politique agricole commune
pour une politique européenne de défense
plus intégrés ou politiques migratoires
ou de lutte contre le terrorisme
est-ce que ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
non non c'est une bonne nouvelle parce
que d'abord je pense que c'est un
raccourci
je pense que d'avoir un pneu hiver vers
des politiques nouvelles et c'est une
évidence la défense la sécurité le
terrorisme
le climat ne doit pas se faire au
détriment d'une autre politique
exactement à la priorité c'est de savoir
quelles exigences oppose auquel quel
rôle on veut donner à l'union européenne
ces rôles à l'échelle intercontinentale
et dont il faudra y mettre les moyens
c'est un enjeu fort mais c'est pas en
sacrifiant les politiques comme la
cohésion où la politique agricole
commune qui traite je le redis de la
santé de l'environnement et de
l'alimentaire donc que l'on va régler le
problème de la défense trois fois de
sérieux mettre en place une défense
commune même si elle est progressive
il faudra vraiment y mettre les moyens
c'est nécessaire mais ça ne se fera pas
à responsabilités au détriment des
politiques agricoles et alimentaires
européennes dont on ne parle pas de
chapitre qui ont la même envergure
depuis des décennies nos militaires sont
envoyés ensemble sur des théâtres
d'opérations sans aucun code
ils ont dû à bout de ficelle montée des
systèmes pour pouvoir communiquer entre
eux ce que nous avons besoin c'est
effectivement d'une vraie architecture
de défense européenne les spécialistes
sexy estime qu'il faut un budget d'un
milliard et demi on est très loin des 53
milliards de la pac
donc on peut pas nous dire ces
substitutions de l'un contre l'autre
politique de défense c'est pareil on va
pas que politique de sécurité
on va pas créer des policiers européens
on a besoin que les polices se fasse
plus confiance entre elles dans les
échanges d'informations donc c'est en
fait dès la travaillent ensemble donc il
faut pas se cacher derrière son petit
doigt
la france doit continuer à défendre ce
qui est son principal retour qui est
l'agriculture
le bénéfice en faveur de l'agriculture
j'attends effectivement qui est une
vraie clarification parce qu'on voit
bien qu'entre le discours du président
la république la semaine dernière à côté
de clermont-ferrand
et puis ce que poussent les diplomates
et les fonctionnaires français envoyés
en mission à bruxelles c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose double discours
potentiellement écouter on suivra en
attendant ce dossier merci à vous de
nous avoir éclairé sur cette question
pour nous c'est la fin
mais pas de panique vous pouvez revoir
bien entendu cette émission sur le web
et nous retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux
la semaine prochaine c'est ahmed tazir
que vous retrouverez à strasbourg très
belle semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]